stéphane ou des quêtes avec les fans ou
des on va revenir dessus dans un instant
il ya le conseil de classe de liberté et
il est avec nous ce soir deux aides
alors la mère je suis comme un génie
pour cette dernière semaine je veux que
du top of the top
alors j'ai appelé plusieurs personnes
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine je veux que du top c'est
pour ça que je voulais démarrer le top
la semaine en folie avec malik bentalha
et mégalithes il apprend que la série
des call j'adore calmy-rey a aidé les
douze entraîneurs de foot acquis coacher
une équipe bretonne mais la température
rien à voir mais ce qui est quand même
c'est un super film valérie benaïm moi
j'ai adoré d'abord j'ai trouvé que alors
je te le dis ma ligue 1 mais tu te tais
solaire un certain temps mais c'est vrai
c'est pas des crèmes solaires
bernard montiel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle vit mais il va du lean et d'une et
eli est formidable en petit merdouille
vraiment une vie et on reviendra sur ce
garçon qui a eu apparemment ses papiers
et son visa grâce à nous il a eu son
visa grâce attouchements mon poste et
nous expliquera tout ça dans un instant
que ce serait quelqu'un avec nous dans
leurs ambitions n'ont pas ces gens merci
sam hamad et il a été maintenant c'est
bon t'as qu'à paris les familles des
comptes avec nous parce que je sais
compter à l'heure était donc tombé la
plateau mon frère vient de m'appeler
s'il est bon et bientôt paul et surtout
plein sans rigoler c'est comme ça ma
mère elle sanglotait dessus omar
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et attends à ce france profonde histoire
vainqueur double et il ya beaucoup de
messages également sur toi stéphane de
gens qui disent c'est fragile
vétérinaire non parce que tu marches
voilà mais on va vous expliquer ce lundi
voilà et de filmer ses fans en fait ils
voient la mêlée à lourdes juste après
[Musique]
il joue même voter die même âge aux
délices eux-mêmes mais on a déjà fait
des matches tous les deux ans où il
était était debout a expliqué marié
j'aime bien venir sur les plateaux et
puis sur le coup deux bouts parce que je
ne savais pas que le tennis en fauteuil
et n'étaient pas réservés aux personnes
qui étaient en fauteuil au quotidien il
se trouve que moi je suis amputé dommage
on gauche au dessus de salou et
j'aimerais bien même que tout le monde
puisse un jour et liouize avait envie de
jouer les jambes aussi amputer un pc à
partager est quand même la soirée
joueurs vous dire les deux personnes
c'est étonnant mais elles n'ont pas dit
non
les horizons elles n'ont pas dit oui
parce que pour l'instant le sentent pas
l'émission s'est confirmée l'année la
production ses fruits chez moi
exactement mon cas c'est sûr à temps
pour savoir qui aura d'autres comme l'a
pour l'instant y'a solitaire faire pour
l'instant c'est dans celle du parquet
alassane d
vous donnez d'ouvrir au point où ils
sont ils ensemble c'est qu'ils m'ont
appelé non jure sur ma dit j'ai moi
aussi maintenant alors vraiment la
poisse
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est mon frère qui s'appelle même
maromme ils ont appelé chemin